[Music]
my merchant mother profit music hall
in ours in South America
/ end to end bizarre land and still
here with heart of course
[Music]
that is
tiger milk is a strong flavor tastes
as if your partner gave you  a kiss and a
slap at the same time my name is take more
i suffered i feel if we are in the
local touch ps in the emerged neighborhood
avenida angamos 886 enigma peru the
ingredients we use are fish celery
garlic or lemon fish broth with
onion cilantro chili  limo we liquefy all that
like this and then we mix it in
parts we complete it with court and
despot chicharrón it is a
refreshing aperitif that apart from being easy to eat on the
street not everyone already knows
ceviche but leche de tigre itself is
the juice  of the ceviche that remains, then, it
is a more powerful concentrate, they
generally use it a lot for
hangovers or to cure heart ailments
[Music]
the tweet at the end of the callao
maker extraordinaire
I think it is special no  I do it
with so much love that people and now
on the street and they tell me like herbie
my name is juan hernández valdez I
am the owner of the don
giuseppe restaurant we meet at
30 grau avenue la punta callao
the street specialty  of the bread
competition a federico sandwich
up to 13 kings together I have made an
omelette first of all you have to
look for the silverside that is ready
then clean the silverside the omelette
has a lot of eggs because you have to be
generous with the egg it is a tempura
throw it  quite a lot and cut their
sentences now of course it comes with onions
its creole sauce that we all prepare at the
moment which is the secret of putting
fish
I have been doing stefan for 25 years and I have
been liking it more and more
in surquillo for months they have
as a class
by themes
[  Music]
you know that we in Peru are
first you get soaked how not to prepare a
delicious potato recipes I'm that kachin
in taxes it's called death here make
we are located in the market number
two of your videos our 620 li mattel
we are dedicated to Creole food and
our specialty is the potato requires
to have the stuffed potato so we cooked
the potato with a little salt we think twice
we go to the stuffing we have onion in
small squares and here special
we went on to add the meat and add the egg, the
olives, the raisins, we returned the potato to the
revoked with an egg beaten with
tuna flour or we went on to fry and everything was
ready
[Music
] whoever tried it would not stop
trying it again when  the clients of usa the
stuffed straw and they leave happy it is a
happiness for me it
was the use of twitter
to be better
[Music]
there is nothing more Lima than a good
dough love
hello I am elena santo my place is called
my sweet company age ignacio  merino
489 miraflores lima but the
purple mazamorra is a kind of pudding made with
purple corn it is boiled and nectar is obtained it
is made with corn cinnamon and
clove well the addition to f  dried
sugar powder diluted sweet potato flour
boiled lemon juice and we even installed love and not
a peculiar flavor not a flavor of corn
with cinnamon and cloves
I have spent years in the kitchen but my
favorite is confectionery for
people and  he tells you how good the mazamorra
is that's the most satisfying thing for one
[Music]
cupcake
I think our cause is richer
because we do it with a lot of love my
name is alberto pérez palma we are in
the port of cafelito the cupcake market
lima peru the flag dish  of this
position is the cause the ingredients the
cause are the chili the lemon the olive the
pepper the lettuce and parsley and the
corn first parboil the peace
to peel it crush it knead with the
yellow fia the lemon and the birds we
put frayed chicken inside in  the
stuffing with its sunrise and molding us the
cause is something special it does not have the taste
of the potato it is a special taste my mom
is what has inspired us because she
was a great co  cinera and he liked to make
the causes that's where we started this
business
[Music]